lass mal probieren dieses ding in der
mitte aus zu checken okay das sind das
eine tun dass junge das natur junge da
ist eine truhe oder was geht ab hier ist
max zusammen mit escape was geht leute
und wir gehen auf den server in drei sei
man erst mal die lage erklären also die
lage ist die folgende wir sind heute
tagesaktuell heißt wir haben nicht
vorproduziert weil es nicht geklappt hat
so letzte folge ist jetzt online die
leute wissen wo wir sind und es kann
sein dass wir jetzt ab gestoppt werden
aber wir leben das jolo laufen deswegen
jetzt drauf 331 und wir haben plan einer
holt food und einer erkundet das ding da
unten
ok heißt es niemand online georg marl
auf die leben alter folgt wieder ein
voll wenig leben ist okay alles klar ich
jump rauskommt noch gut und du gehst in
die elegante alles lässt jetzt ich habe
nämlich auch gar keinen putt männer also
wäre es wirklich dass daran gelegen ist
der ballon alter was ich dem fall hielt
gegeben habe du bist ja noch geschützt
ja weißt was ich bin nicht mehr
geschützt du was machst du mit dem court
ich habe kurz mal gescreent
dies ist ja es sind doch gute plan ist
hast du ja schon erklärt wir haben ja
diese höhle gefunden und mir wurde
zugetragen dass das das größte special
in minecraft halten ist und das heißt
wir können damit also einiges machen
ich muss mal nach oben mir ein bisschen
holz holen damit ich weiter hier mit der
spitzhacke marschieren kann
brände gab es nicht da diese zum brennen
der und ist nämlich alles von diesem von
diesen metall was woraus man sich ein
ziemlich gutes zu machen kann und damit
könnten wir dann halt und anfänglichen
nachteil kann man schon sagen ein
bisschen ausreichen
ich finde hier auch erstmal also ich
sehe hier draußen keine tiere ist wird
nach verringern
bitte danach warum
ich weiß nicht und die rabbids aber wie
kerber kiel fleisch zudrop nicht die
spur von dem also ich eben wie viel
essen als du noch bei mir ist nicht mehr
so hier ich bin jetzt gerade sind durch
die fleisch und die nach bregenz
ok erstmals erprobt
ich bin besorgt so viel du kannst weil
ich würde also wie kannst du so viel
mehr als ich sah wie fleisch aber ich
hab jetzt zumindest mal ich habe
zumindest mal ein rapid und drei schwein
kann jemand bitte irgendwo ein und kommt
ja ich bin ich seit ewigkeiten hier nur
durch was ich glaub schon mal wieder
zurück bin ist es unendlich dunkel wird
jetzt macht oder wie ja es ist schon
acht es ist schon hart finstere nacht
aber das ist gut
ich kann nicht sprinten ja ich kann ewig
schon vor allem ist es verdammt dunkler
streetlife dafür
ich hoffe nur dass ich jetzt ein
wir brauchen wir wirklich nur 1 1 ändern
können uns echt gutes soll ja genau der
clubs nämlich diese citrin rüstung für
alle die es nicht wissen wo jack
schicken jeher noch letzte kumpel und
scharfe kritik das ist irgendwie ich
glaube dass das sehr das eisenvorkommen
muss irgendwie krass genau weil ich
genervt sein
quaas reduziert ich habe tennis ist bis
ein bisschen viel in ein bisschen rabbit
meditec hälfte einfach mal bisschen
siehst du schon wo ich bin ich mach hier
gerade und strip main und es passiert
nichts sehe ich kann auch nicht spenden
ich spaziere jetzt mountain in die höhle
rhein fiel mir schon aufgenommen
aber die höhe und hab also wir haben auf
jeden fall richtig viel stoff geld ist
in der höhe
selbst ja auch noch alle genau dass
manche also da will ich mal runter gehen
ich mache hier gerade aufs tritt man so
ein bisschen weil ich dachte es müsste
was kommen und es ist einfach viel zu
dunkel also ich sehe gar nichts
ok also ein eisen habe wir noch im rufen
ein eisen habe ich noch im inventar wir
uns auch ich habe auch schon was von
diesem roten ohr gefunden
das ist das rote noch mal wer hier ist
weißt du was das rote ist zufällig das
rote weil sich nicht nur das wort redet
ihr irgendeine tot dann was irgendwie
auch modus wo man sich das anzeigen
lassen kann wo man drauf schaut gerade
also wenn wir auf jeden fall hin die ok
perfekt ich hab noch ein eisen gefunden
jetzt jetzt jetzt jetzt jetzt jungen ab
dem es trade ist die aschwer alter oder
manager schwer ja wir sind auf jeden
fall eines einheit ein dia blöcke okay
aber uns ist niemand nach geräumt da ist
nur ein dia block doch konnten die da
oben sind ganz böse noch wesentlich mehr
noch ja ich sehe gerade einen leisen so
ein seltenes aber egal wer mir ein arsch
voll citrin also entschuldigt die
wortwahl aber so ist ich habe vor allem
ein wenig an der k geboren essen denn
ich brauche dringend geschoben was oder
bronze zu lang da kommt nehme ich habe
noch ein halber hungerberg krieg gleich
schaden
ok dann kommen wir kommen ruhig entgegen
ja ich habe ein bisschen also vielleicht
sechs sieben gebrannt das fleisch das
perfekt dann kann ich mich vielleicht
einmal komplett krieg schon okay du bist
einfach den gang runter ich komme blogs
hier hast du das alles bietet was hast
du das ein mann kann nicht mit strg
dürfen
nee das geht nicht warum das denn keine
ahnung das ist irgendwie immer so das
war auch bei legend somit man kann nicht
mit s t ag alles raus trocken
wahrscheinlich damit man das bisschen
behindert bin ich die leute ja wir haben
unser eisen junge jetzt wird die
trikotfarben sven die erste farbe wieso
ist denn jemand dieser eine dir meine
letzte folge gesehen
das ing us waren hast du vielleicht
halle 10 was ich hier unterbaut bitte
ich habe mich nicht weitergebaut seiten
also entweder wir an das oder jemand hat
sich umgeschaut aber da will ich würde
ich mich sehr wundern warum er denn
nicht das nicht abgebauten citrin ja ja
das ist komplett komplett crazy okay man
wahrscheinlich allem pickel
aber da drin der trick ist um dieses
citrin schwert aus den blüten zu kräften
das übrigens gold braucht man nicht den
üblichen stick sondern das habe ich dann
noch mal nachgeschaut man braucht ein
smart handle und das besteht aus zwei
reisen also romans das gleich mal nice
citrin ist angefahren werden euch bei
uns ein bisschen legen welche auf dem
tsv das kein ding gar nicht dann bin ich
vielleicht einfach nur am abspeisen
so aber also ich hab ich noch mal einen
level cockpit und kann ich dir droppen
dann versuchen wir zu wenig wie möglich
zu springen aber beim verbraucht man die
voll wenig energie wir gehen dann
einfach jetzt runter in diese fette
henne oder so ein bisschen mehr mut
holen wo vorausfahrender ausfüllen so 80
euro aufgenommen es ist draußen nacht
das nicht sogar die rüstung was braucht
man dafür lassen ein bisschen was in den
ofen
du musst dir einfach nur brennen weißt
du was ich gerade dass sie das geht aber
nicht offen
doch nicht also es brennt nicht im
regulären offen ist jeder noch mal
informieren
aber vielleicht in ofenerdiek ofen gibt
es sowas ja offen gibt dann wird das
wahrscheinlich dafür aber alter aber
einmal ist das so selten ja wir haben
ist einfach pech gehabt
okay ich gehe mal runter in diese halle
die ich mir gemacht in diese den
strippen eingang die stadt leistet haben
bisschen orientierungslos anschlag oder
ein bisschen schwein und diese halle
sind halt irgendwie todes höfen
einerseits und andererseits aber so
normale oft auch irgendwie weniger da
gehe ich lieber mal in strip mein gang
als darunter schon zu gehen aber ich
habe auf jeden 32 von diesem grünen
finden und wir waren in schweinefleisch
ein wie viele vor den 32 von den citrin
ja sehr nice hast du alles abgebaut was
da oben ist sowas oben ist habe ich
abgebaut und unten in der höhle ist ja
noch mehr und jetzt habe ich auch hier
ist mein kleines kägi alter ich bin so
froh dass ich fast food haben junge das
war das größte problem bei legend damals
mit alkohol dass wir einfach kein food
hatten bauer habe ich hier gut der ist
ja auch im bereich und richtig gut man
wird ja auch eine flut von daher
wir können uns gleich schwer darauf
machen auszeit hat mir täglich 88 effekt
damit ist ein schwert zu machen
für op feile und ich hab ich habe fünf
da kam ihr einbau und ein schwert
vielleicht okay ich hab jetzt ein
bisschen food geholt kommen jetzt mal
rein in die hört wieder
ich glaube ich hätte auslassen sollen
als ich teilten zeugen junge ich glaube
es ist gut
du kannst einfach jetzt wahrscheinlich
zusammen scheinbar haben wir etwas gutes
gefunden leute die wendung also das
glück bei uns holt diese wendung hatten
wir uns echt verdient nach diesem ersten
sehr sehr suboptimalen start
ich habe ein bisschen mutig bau ab komm
runter dann schön wir uns morgen und
land zusammen reise von brand
ich habe noch holz mitnehmen ich bin in
der nasenhöhle ist der kohle kohle kohle
ist hier auch sogar eine menge sehr gut
einmal auf einfach mal diesen gar nicht
gewahrt klar nämlich keine sommer mit
aaron stone zu ballern adjusted ziemlich
alles gebrauchen
alles was du willst tommy habe die
panthers warst bild ich habe jetzt fünf
schweine hasen
aber das ist richtig so das ist richtig
weil ich keine fakten
okay dann ist es das erste mal wieder qr
code von hass holz für die fackel ja
seine ich habe 22 holz oder weilbach mal
hast du überhaupt holz dabei sieben
reisen mit bio alter was das junge alter
op schwert incoming dass ich mal kurz
checken was sie für dieses teams dort
brauchen aber mach bitte fackeln hier
also also kann holz ich habe hier müssen
ich brauche meine kräfte auf kraft sind
tables und da gucken mal kurz an diesen
zeiten schwer das ist ich glaube dass
dieses titels zu recht op ist was wir
gerade ganz erfinden und ich habe jetzt
schon über 10 von teilten sword 2 2001
ort händel hingeht wie macht man den in
gradiska dann kann man ja auch
nachschauen in ein fernes okay dann
brauchen wir den unbedingten ich glaube
ist vielleicht diese diese folge noch
machen okay ich habe ja auch noch mal 3
die brände waren wir künstlich den fans
machen auf jeden fall auch noch eine
ganze menge aber frage ist das brennen
wir jetzt hier wird mir erst einen
längeren okay dann komm her dann mache
ich jetzt mal nämlich mein lover einmal
ein fernes machen wir es mal ja ich habe
wie viel hast du hier zehn ja easy
debatte warte dann mache ich ja zum
brennen aber du kannst mal schauen was
es für einen in gebrauch von diesem
citrin weimar brennen hatte ja einfach
in den alters- und brennen dann ist das
ja viel zu viel wasser in der wüste war
herrlich x breite x 112 hatte einst die
training geht ist einfach ein ohr
gebrannt junge wir können es jeden fall
wir können es zumindestens mal eine
frist um zwei schwerter machen da sind
wir eben also im fullscreen vale
disziplin da rein
ja man hat mir das neueste citrin er
waren all area man natürlich davon ist
nun eiswette was wir noch lesen
also wir hatten glaube ich einfach nur
echt eine menge pech
am anfang ja glaub ich auch mal hatte
ich so mehr kohle dann tags gar nicht so
der scheiß drei wer als mister nice guy
13 minuten 13 minuten das läuft jeden
fall dann sind wir gleich bei der citrin
rüstung kommt noch mal runter oder wie
sagt haben jetzt die große höhle doch
gar nicht geholt
das ist ja das ganze citrin bin ich habe
jetzt schon 57 ja dann dann lass uns
doch mal die zieht in die höhe über step
und da lassen schnell mitnehmen oder
warten jetzt bei 13 42 dass wir uns
vielleicht in der höhle die nächste
folge anfang okay wir können auf jeden
fall genug material für den alten den
firnis kann uns holen sehr durch rabatte
dann hast du dass das fleisch
mitgenommen habe ich mit sodann
abgeschafft das sollte klappen sollte
kommen okay wir haben 14 minuten
aufnahmezeit jetzt und ich hab vor einem
12 2
das heißt wir uns beschwert junge reiter
das ist richtig op wir können uns
überlegen ob man vielleicht so random
einen tighten einzieht resort auf die
zwei auf die eins machen dann immer
zwischen ein paar hits geben citrin
abreisen chance hat 85 prozent wenn alle
titan youtuber die jetzt auch grad schon
cloud nicht unsere tipps orient rallye
personal aufpassen auf max bitte mach
kein käse ich mache was ich mal ich mach
block immer die junge so nice oder von
degas da vorne ist irgend so ein fitter
brunnen in der mitte was du willst so
wir wo wir uns hier herunter junge wie
weit es darunter gehen alter heute
folgte in der mitte ist ein brunnen
lassen probieren noch auszustechen ich
glaube da ist die wahre op ist hinter
dieser schlucht wort penis oder wie in
europa ist penis aber jetzt nicht nicht
nicht übereilen dies noch über viele
vereine sind es dann für eines das ist
doch eine wand ist drin runter hier
randy mache die brennen hat wie bringen
wir können die berechnung das was drin
ist extrem man was brennen lassen hat
sechs ok ab lasst mal probieren dieses
ding in der mitte aus zu checken
ich kann schon nicht mehr sprechen warte
ich nicht aber du hast das fleisch darum
dass sie damit aber jetzt gab es nun das
wetter zombies oder
dass der so cool stehe okay dass das
eine tun dass junge dass eine tour junge
da ist eine truhe und das ist die tour
innerhalb des kicker teil alter lasst
den cliffhanger auf du machen wir öffnet
die tür in der nächsten folge als
nächstes nicht ehrlich da nämlich den
räumlichkeiten
wenn man noch eine menge zeit pharmazie
trainer alles ab was aber nein wir
machen nicht dieses bekam alles ab was
du nicht rein bekommen kannst werfen das
nicht in der nächsten folge ja egal aber
fand trotzdem citrin aber erst mal du
das auch machen oder wir schauen
gleichzeitig an junge ist eine falle
vielleicht aber negativ fallen mir jetzt
gut ausfallen aber dann geh du auf jeden
fall mal 30 blöcke weg oder so fahren
ist kein scheiß ich glaube es findet
können wir das irgendwie junge wie
komisch das aussieht guckt euch das an
leute das gibt's doch nicht soll ich das
jetzt aufmachen oder der nächsten folge
ich weiß es nicht geweckt nicht das ja
effekt ausgelöst wird macht es auch okay
ich stelle mir ich weiß es nicht man ja
ok 321 und sieht was einst sieht ja was
ist los mit euch man dann eher die ja
ein fucking sie da drin und wir wurden
gekippt wort [ __ ] alter war da jemand
davor dran oder ich war durch der
eigentlich dass das ein toller wupsi
fanden schon da oben das lockt control
alt dann hat er uns verarschen op oder
der eigene der eigentliche schatz direkt
darunter wir schauen auf jeden fall in
der nächsten folge nach leute lassen
möchte gefallen hat haut rein macht's
gut und